bonjour à tous bienvenue sur public
sénat ce matin nous vous proposons de
suivre une audition qui a eu lieu hier
après midi au sénat
une audition de cécile duflot la
ministre de l'égalité des territoires et
du logement a été entendu par les
sénateurs de la commission du
développement durable ainsi que la
commission des affaires économiques
la ministre est intervenu pour présenter
sa feuille de route en matière d'égalité
des territoires elle a rappelé en quoi
il s'agissait d'un sujet absolument
primordial en effet notamment après
l'élection présidentielle
on a constaté que l'extrême droite avait
fait des scores sans précédent dans des
territoires jusque là préservé tout de
suite donc retour à cette audition qui a
eu lieu il ya après midi en salle
clémenceau d'un ministre merci bienvenue
au sénat sont très honoré et très
heureux de vous accueillir
le préambule doit être très court
puisque tous mes collègues ici présent
que je salue honteux attendu un certain
temps donc simplement pour vous dire que
vous êtes en présence des élus des deux
commission de l'économie et du
développement durable cette deuxième
commission qui vient d'être créé
récemment et qui évidemment intègre la
thématique de l'aménagement du
territoire sur lequel mes collègues et
moi même sommes impatients de vous
entendre donc je vais laisser la parole
à daniel raoul pour dire deux mots
d'accueil et ensuite nous vous donnons
la parole tout de suite pour essayer
d'avoir un dialogue constructif et
informatif merci madame la ministre mes
chers collègues je suis très heureux de
vous accueillir ici dans cette
configuration qui réunit les deux
commissions mais vous savez très bien ce
que je pense de cette scission serait
pas revenir l'étude
et donc est donc je pense que les sujets
qui préoccupent les deux commissions
sont totalement identiques et en
particulier ce qui concerne l'égalité
des territoires le logement et le
développement sont durables et donc que
je vous laisse tout de suite la parole
madame messieurs les présidents je vous
remercie beaucoup je vous prie
évidemment d'excusés mon retard ou à
votre rendez vous laisser notre retard
collectif et je m'en serais évidemment
voulu écourter un débat parlementaire
très intéressant sur un sujet qui n'est
pas un sujet mineur puisque l'abrogation
de cette loi sur la constructibilité
super de 30% a donné lieu à des échanges
approfondis sur la nécessité mais je
vais y revenir d'un travail
parlementaire sur les questions pas
seulement d'aménagement du territoire
mais aussi sur les questions de règles
d'urbanisme ou les collectivités locales
sont dans la tente d'une vision à la
fois plus simple plus claire et plus
évidente de l'ensemble de ces sujets
qu'ils puissent aussi nous permettre
collectivités locales et l'état de
poursuivre un objectif cet objectif
c'est celui de résoudre la crise du
logement que connaissent un certain
nombre de nos territoires je suis donc
tout particulièrement honorés d'être
devant vous pour présenter l'action du
ministère de l'égalité des tur des
territoires et du logement dans la
chambre dont celle objet puisque le
sénat et la chambre même des territoires
donc ça aura eu un sens que mon premier
travail de ministre devant
une des chambres ce soit devant le sénat
que ce soit ces deux commissions que je
rencontre aujourd'hui puisque le sénat
est d'ailleurs l'ensemble des élus
locaux ont vu se succéder au cours des
dernières années des projets multiples
et des visions fort différente en
matière de territoire depuis l'ambition
planificatrice des années 60 jusqu'aux
politiques de dérégulation en passant
par l'étape significative et historique
de la décentralisation au cours des dix
dernières années en revanche il semblait
s'être installé l'idée que l'aménagement
du territoire se trouver dépourvu d'un
objectif clair voire d'une ambition
nationale qui laissait coexister et se
juxtaposer des politiques territoriales
diverses aux ambitions parfois inégal
sans objectif politique significatif
l'aménagement du territoire a parfois
été abandonnée au danger et du laisser
faire qui a trop souvent rimé pour
certains espaces avec abandon et avec
relégation
le mandat que nous a confié le présent
la république est claire il avait d'ores
et déjà exprimé lors de sa campagne et
la feuille de route s'est trouvée
confirmés et précisés par le discours de
politique générale du premier ministre
que vous avez entendu devant vous la
semaine dernière notre mission est de
placer l'ensemble des politiques de
territoires sous le sceau ambitieux mais
absolument nécessaire de l'égalité en
matière de territoire l'égalité ne veut
évidemment pas dire l'uniformité où
l'unicité
mais c'est en reconnaissant la diversité
des contextes locaux en leur donnant
comme seule perspective aux politiques
publiques en donnant comme seule
perspective aux politiques publiques
l'ambition de justice de justice sociale
évidemment mais également de justice
territoriale
c'est donc une mission nouvelle pour les
institutions de la république et en
particulier pour l'état comme le fut à
une époque et je ne reviendrai pas sur
le débat que vous avez évoqué en
introduction mais comme fut à l'époque
j'en reste une partie d'un engagé celui
du développement durable une mission
nouvelle certes mais qui renoue avec
cette volonté de mettre les territoires
au coeur de la république
comme beaucoup d'entre vous qui sont
attachés au cours des dernières années
parce que notre constat ici est simple
aujourd'hui chaque français connaît sur
son territoire une entreprise qui a
délocalisé pour réduire ses coûts
chaque français voient dans le même
temps dans son commune dans sa commune
dans son département dans sa région
s'enchaîner les fermetures de classes du
réseau d'aidés spécialisées aux élèves
en difficulté
je vais prendre devant vous quelques
exemples qui permettent de le situer les
choses mais dans le département de la
moselle
ce sont 5000 400 postes de militaires
quatre tribunaux d'instance de conseils
de prud'hommes 267 postes dans le seul
primaire une prison une quinzaine de
brigade au peloton de gendarmerie qui
ont été supprimés en quelques années et
ça ne peut pas se faire sans laisser de
trace et de traces forte dans un
territoire à joigny dans l'yonne en
douze ans la ville a connu la fermeture
de la maternité du service de chirurgie
de départ du 28e régiment de
cartographie militaire la fermeture des
tribunaux d'instance et du tribunal de
commerce
et il ne reste que 24 agents de pôle
emploi pour 2008 129 demandeurs d'emploi
je pourrais poursuivre sur ce constat et
pour coup je pourrais également dresser
une liste exhaustive qui serait à la
fois fastidieux mais qui prouverait que
ce constat partagé est sans équivoque
les français ont envoyé à ce sujet un
message politique sans détour et sans
hésitation lors du premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle l'extrême
droite a remporté des scores sans
précédent dans des territoires qui en
étaient jusqu'alors préservée dans les
campagnes dans les quartiers dans les
villes petites et moyennes vient se
mêler à la désespérance sociale qui naît
de la crise un sentiment de relégation
et d'abandon de la puissance publique
les français sont à la fois déstabilisé
par les effets incontrôlée et injuste
d'une mondialisation sans limites mais
ils sont aussi victimes d'une réforme de
l'état mener parfois de manière
désorganisée et incontrôlée les services
publics ne joue plus toujours leur rôle
là où il devrait être une puissance
d'intégration ils deviennent facteurs
d'abandon dès lors c'est un sentiment de
méfiance et d'inquiétude qui vient à
naître c'est alors l'individualisme qui
prospèrent l'égoïsme des âges qui
progressent et le lien social qui se
délite
l'état doit retrouver pleinement son
rôle non pas celui d'un état
planificateur qui décide de tout mais
qui ne parvient plus à rien mais au
contraire celui d'un état stratège d'un
état qui accompagnent les citoyens qui
accompagne les collectivités locales et
leurs élus dans les objectifs de
réalisations qui sont les leurs
l'égalité des territoires ce nouveau
chemin de l'action de l'état ce n'est
pas seulement d'assurer plus ou mieux
pour quelques-uns ce n'est pas seulement
fondé des politiques pour des quartiers
réservés ou des territoires protégés
c'est essayer d'avoir une politique qui
donne à tous les habitants les mêmes
possibilités pour choisir leur vie si
nous voulons assurer au plus grand
nombre un sort meilleur un accès au
logement aux services publics aux biens
publics l'eau l'air un environnement
sain nous devons faire progresser
l'accès au droit et envisager les
problèmes territoire par territoire
nous devons faire en sorte que les 85%
populations qui vivent en ville y vivent
bien dans tous ses quartiers
mais nous devons aussi permettre que
toutes celles et ceux qui ont fait le
choix de vivre loin des villes ou dans
de petites villes ne soient pas privés
de l'accès aux services prévus pour tous
nous devons reposer la question des
relations entre les centres villes les
banlieues et les territoires ruraux
nous devons repenser les relations entre
les grandes aires métropolitaines dont
la région capitale et au reste des
territoires
en somme il s'agit de repenser la
solidarité de repenser toute la
solidarité à l'échelle nationale comme à
l'échelle régionale et à l'échelle
locaux locale parce que les problèmes
sociaux sont en effet aujourd'hui
multiples et diffuse des quartiers
dégradés parfois en situation de grande
souffrance sociale peuvent se trouver
très loin de la région capitale à
limoges ou à grande synthe la question
sociale ne se limite pas aux quartiers
populaires le statut d'ouvrier concerne
plus de 60% des hommes ruraux actifs et
seulement 54% des citadins et 18 % des
femmes rurales active contre 9 % des
urbaines
on a peut parfois un peu de mal à
justement avoir une vision très précise
de ce qu'est la réalité territoriale de
notre pays aujourd'hui et c'est pourquoi
la politique de la ville doit aussi être
repensée et mon collègue françois lamy
attache une importance toute
particulière parce que la question des
quartiers censier des quartiers
sensibles doit être pensée comme elle se
doit
s'ils se concentrent dans les quartiers
des difficultés sociales et de violence
ce sont les inégalités au sein d'une
même agglomération qui sont parfois les
plus frappantes dans une même ville on
trouve dans des quartiers séparés toutes
les situations sociales et l'éventail de
tous les territoires
chacun chez soi à la fois tout près et
en même temps
loin ainsi dans un même centre urbain on
voit cohabiter la grande bourgeoisie
avec des cadres des professions
intellectuelles et des catégories
populaires souvent issus de
l'immigration avec des fossés qui se
creusent des inégalités qui progresse
chaque année l'observatoire des us nous
montre que les quartiers sensibles
voient leurs conditions de vie se
dégrader et l'inégalité avec les 113 et
progresser quand les métropoles
s'embourgeoise de plus en plus le
renforcement des inégalités est presque
mécanique
mais si la carte des territoires
s'appuyer sur des données exclusivement
sociales
elle ne ressemblerait absolument pas à
la scène actuelle les quartiers
sensibles
la montée du rsa dans les territoires
ruraux en témoigne si c'était nécessaire
parce qu'un français sur deux n'a beat
pas dans un grand centre urbain
près des deux tiers des communes de plus
de 50 mille habitants ont perdu des
habitants entre 1975 et 1990 au profit
de la périphérie depuis 1975 ce sont les
communes rurales périurbaines celles qui
sont dans la mouvance de grandes
agglomérations qui se développe le plus
vite
et cette réorganisation qui avait
commencé à s'essouffler reprend depuis
dix ans la fracture territoriale et
c'est très important de pouvoir le dire
aujourd'hui n'est pas toujours une
fracture sociale elle est
essentiellement marquée par
l'éloignement de service publie
désormais essentiel l'école la santé la
sécurité les transports qui obligent des
populations entières à rester dépendante
de leur automobile
il n'est pas de situations univoque il
n'est pas de solution unique
c'est le coeur de l'état d'esprit du
ministère de l'égalité des territoires
et du logement
nous devons trouver une réponse pour
chaque territoire pour les quartiers
sensibles pour les villes petites et
moyennes
pour les territoires ruraux à faible
densité cela appelle aussi des solutions
adaptées aux territoires l'époque où
l'aménagement se dessinait sur des plans
et des schémas loin des territoires de
leurs habitants de leurs élus est révolu
je souhaite associer pleinement les
habitants mais aussi et d'abord leurs
élus à la construction de ces politiques
l'égalité des territoires se doit
d'accompagner l'acte iii de la
décentralisation que nous engagerons en
s'appuyant sur des relations nouvelles
entre l'état et les collectivités
il s'agit de mettre en oeuvre une
contractualisation nouvelle partager et
équitable nous nous devons aussi de
répondre aux nouvelles questions qui
s'ouvre à nous
nous devons mieux prendre en compte le
fait métropolitain et son évolution
repenser les relations entre les régions
ne plus considérer que les relations
entre les territoires doivent être
basées sur la compétition mais valorisé
soutenir une pleine coopération entre
les territoires
l'égalité des territoires c'est aussi et
avant tout une politique qui se trouve
au coeur de la transit de la transition
écologique
c'est au plus près des territoires que
nous pourrons enraciné un modèle de
développement soutenable économe de la
ressource
soucieux des habitants comme de
l'environnement dans les zones
périurbaines
nous devrons entendre les attentes des
habitants pour une meilleure desserte et
une plus grande écoute tout en luttant
vigoureusement contre l'étalement urbain
et l'artificialisation des sols dans les
zones rurales qui produisent notre rôle
sera d'y maintenir et de renforcer une
activité de proximité tout en donnant un
nouveau souffle aux villes et aux bourgs
dans les campagnes abandonné aujourd'hui
nous devrons être vigilants à ce que la
présence du service public soit
maintenue mais aussi à ce qu'elles
deviennent des espaces pour tous d
espace d'innovation et de création elles
en ont les ressources concernant les
quartiers urbains sensibles
il nous faudra mettre un terme à des
situations insupportables pour la
république sur des territoires où se
cumulent toutes les inégalités où il est
question de chômage de sécurité d'accès
aux services notamment publics
d'enclavement se pose de façon choquante
à ce jour à clichy-montfermeil toujours
aucune agence de pôle emploi pas de
transport urbain à clichy comme ailleurs
la question n'est pas locale et ne revel
ne recèle pas seulement de la
responsabilité des élus
c'est un enjeu national auquel l'état et
le gouvernement doit apporter des
réponses
cela n'empêche pas les collectivités de
s'approprier les sujets et d'ajouter à
la responsabilité de l'état leur
connaissance du terrain mais en manière
des galets en matière d'égalité c'est la
république qui est responsable et l'état
qui doit en être le garant
je veux donc posé la question l'égalité
des territoires de trois façons d'abord
comme une politique de réparation envers
les territoires meurtri ensuite comme
une politique de solidarité et de
cohésion entre les territoires
enfin comme une politique d'accès aux
services publics pour tous et toutes
le premier défi sera de réparer les
territoires meurtri je veux revoir la
géographie
prioritaire il y a aujourd'hui 13 zonage
différentes
la nouveauté de l'intitulé de notre
ministère ne doit plus nous amener à
traiter les thématiques de manière
éparse et désordonnée c'est une approche
globale de chaque territoire qui peut
nous permettre d'apporter une réponse à
toutes les difficultés qui le traversent
la prise de conscience a eu lieu et la
nécessité d'une action conjointe et
coordonnée sur tous les territoires
meurtri est évidente
il ne s'agit plus d'opposer le rural à
l'urbain ni de laisser les uns ou les
autres sur le bord des chemins de la
république
cet effort et je le dis avec solennité
devant vous ne peut pas être décrétée
depuis paris les qualités des
territoires implique en effet la
délibération collective de toutes les
parties prenantes
elle appelle une connaissance fine des
territoires une mise en cohérence des
efforts de chacun des régions dont le
rôle en matière de développement
économique ou de formation
professionnelle est indispensable pour
agir pour le développement des
territoires meurtrie des départements
dont la mission d'insertion sociale doit
être articulée avec celle des autres
acteurs des groupements de communes et
de leurs adhérents dont le rôle de
proximité et chaque jour essentielles
l'égalité des territoires commandes
surtout une participation de tous les
habitants que les premiers juges de
l'efficacité des mesures décidées soient
les citoyens il faut faire confiance à
l'intelligence des territoires et leur
redonner les moyens de reprendre en main
la maîtrise de leur avenir en matière de
politique de la ville
le gouvernement prendra rapidement des
mesures d'urgence dans trois domaines il
rétablira l'égalité sociale en créant
cent cinquante mille emplois d'avenir
dans les communes qui connaissent à la
fois un taux de chômage élevé et une
pénurie de services publics il rétablira
l'égalité devant la loi
en déployant des effectifs de police
supplémentaires il luttera pour
l'égalité des chances en affectant
prioritairement des emplois créés dans
l'éducation nationale aux écoles situées
dans les quartiers populaires et en
créant un droit un capital formation
pour tous jeunes qui décrochent
je souhaite engager la suppression des
zonages au profit d'un périmètre unique
qui se situera les quartiers défavorisés
dans les dynamiques d'agglomération au
service d'un projet global de territoire
il distinguera la situation des villes
qui ont des quartiers défavorisés des
villes entièrement défavorisés il
ciblera les territoires qui ont
structurellement peu de ressources
et beaucoup de charges sociaux urbaine
il proposera un contrat unique déterminé
en cohérence avec le périmètre
prioritaires transversale aux différents
champs d'intervention intégrant dans un
même mouvement les projets de
développement social et de rénovation
urbaine
on ne peut pas dissocier l'humain de
l'urbain l'expérience que l'on sur
lequel on commence à avoir du recul de
l'anru nous démontre chaque jour s'il en
était besoin cette nécessité
le programme national de rénovation
urbaine que je viens d'évoquer sera
menée à son terme et nous souhaitons
qu'une nouvelle étape s'engage avant la
fin de la mandature
le deuxième défi consiste à restaurer la
solidarité entre les territoires et la
cohésion nationale le relevé passe par
une politique de péréquation rénové
entre collectivités riches et
collectivités pauvres entre territoires
aisée et territoires fragiles répondre à
ce défi passe aussi par une politique
raisonnée d'aménagement du territoire
qui assure la mixité sociale
la conciliation des espaces naturels
agricoles et urbanisé et développe la
capacité de chaque territoire à trouver
des relais de croissance
le sentier de son développement je
souhaite contribuer à la diversification
des modèles de développement par le
tourisme par l'économie rurale par
l'économie sociale et solidaire par la
politique territoriale de l'enseignement
supérieur de la recherche et de
l'innovation
autant de levier pour ré articulé au
niveau régional les liens ville campagne
autour de circuits courts de solidarités
nouvelles de filières régionales
créatrice de valeur autour d'un tissu de
pme qui doivent être mieux accompagnés
le troisième défi sera de s'assurer de
la permanence d'un service rendu au
public en fonction des besoins propres
de chacun des territoires en y affectant
les moyens de droit commun territoire
par territoire
à raison de 6 pi 6 de ses spécificités
il faudra rétablir l'égalité non
seulement devant les charges publiques
mais également dans l'accès aux services
publics
je veux que les effectifs ainsi que
toutes les dépenses d'intervention de
gros droit commun de l'état qui ne sont
pas destinés aux ménages soit affectée
sur la base d'un diagnostic territorial
d'un dialogue puis d'un contrat passé
entre les taïko les collectivités pour
que chacun s'engage sur les moyens
attribués à chacun des territoires
la crédibilité du gouvernement j'en ai
conscience passera par sa capacité à
rétablir l'égalité et la justice dans la
répartition des moyens de droit commun à
affecter les effectifs et à flécher les
dépenses d'intervention vers les
collectivités les plus démunis à partir
d'un diagnostic partagé un bouquet de
services adaptée au territoire doit être
offert à l'ensemble des français et
garantir et ce sera une des clés sans
doute de cette politique d'égalité des
territoires que le temps d'accès aux
services publics de la santé ou de
l'éducation demeure raisonnable pour
tous l'heure est venue de conjuguer
présence physique de proximité et
téléservices de désenclaver les
territoires par une politique adéquate
de transport et de développement
j'allais dire de couverture de
l'ensemble du pays par le réseau
numérique à haut débit les choses sont
évidentes quand vous m'avez écouté je ne
pourrais pas à moi seul même ministre de
l'égalité des territoires relever tous
ces défis la plupart des questions
concrètement poser ici sont par nature
interministériel et je pense peut-être
que c'est cette démarche cette
dimension-là qui a fait sans doute
qu'elle se pose avec beaucoup d'acuité
dans un certain nombre de territoires de
notre pays
elle appelle donc à une vigilance de
tous et notamment de la représentation
nationale
si vous me permettez je voudrais en
lister quelques unes sur lesquels je
veux travailler avec vous et sur
lesquels je souhaiterais pouvoir aussi
compter sur vous le premier point je
viens de l'évoquer c'est tenir
l'engagement présidentiel d'une
couverture haut débit puis très haut
débit pour tous c'est évidemment une
nécessité en tant que politique
d'investissement d'investissements
publics dans les réseaux parce qu'elle
favorise le développement sans renforcer
forcément les zones métropolitaines
c'est une nécessité en tant que
politique d'aménagement équilibré du
territoire parce qu'elle facilite la
diffusion des services et remédier aux
inégalités à la fracture numérique qui a
tendance à se creuser chaque du jour
davantage du fait du renforcement des
besoins en débit de différents services
et c'est enfin une nécessité parce
qu'elle peut constituer un levier de
développement de nouveaux services
notamment par le secteur privé selon un
modèle à inventer mais qui pourrait être
celui de la transformation d'une partie
de la mine
l'administration plateforme grâce à
l'open data sur lesquels sur laquelle se
grefferait opérateurs proposant des
services élaborés à partir des données
de l'administration
ceci ne veut pas dire que cette
couverture nécessaire sera le prétexte
pour diminuer la présence des services
publics
au contraire rien ne remplace la
rencontre physique et je crois qu'il
faut le redire je dois m'appuyer aussi
sur le travail qui a été mené par le
conseil économique et social
environnemental qui a pointé la
l'accroissement de la fracture entre les
citoyens les services publics du fait de
l'absence de contact physique et je
crois qu'il est très important de
maintenir cette dimension humaine parce
que là des yeux la déshumanisation du
service au public est facteur de
dépression généralisée je pense qu'il
est très important en 2012 d'être
parfaitement conscient des limites de
l'adema de matérialisation de l'accès
aux services publics
et je crois donc que le numérique peut
être l'occasion de ré articuler les
fonctions d'accueil d'orientation de
conseil et d'appui qui suppose la
rencontre physique et l'écoutent et la
fonction d'administration de procédure
qui la nécessite pas partout avec la
même intensité
vous aurez compris je souhaite qu'on
puisse maintenir et travailler à une un
développement de services publics qui
assure l'accueil avec une présence
physique et qui permettent grâce au
numérique de réorienter vers différents
types de services administratifs
deuxième défi très important c'est
d'assurer l'accès en un temps
raisonnable et j'insiste sur le terme
tant il ne s'agit pas de mesures et en
distance mais de bien pouvoir s'adapter
à la spécificité des territoires en
particulier des territoires de montagne
ou des territoires plus enclavées donc
l'accès en un temps raisonnable aux
services essentiels pour tous l'école et
la petite enfance la santé les loisirs
je sais que la présence médicale sur
tous les territoires est un sujet que
vous avez pris ici à bras le corps dans
vos territoires c'est évident mais ici
au sénat et je suivrai avec beaucoup
d'attention les conclusions du groupe de
travail présenté par monsieur fisher
réussir le renouvellement des voies de
chemin de fer et relancer une ambition
nationale de désenclavement
c'est le troisième point très important
parce qu'il me semble qu'il faut
décliner dans des schémas régionaux des
objectifs d'amélioration de
l'accessibilité la desserte des
territoires réels
désenclavement supposant l'accès à un
centre urbain ou économiques en un délai
raisonnable cette question du temps est
aussi un point essentiel sur l'accès aux
transports pour donner un nouvel élan à
la une politique territorialisée de
soutien à l'innovation et à transition
écologique
nos outils d'anticipation et
d'accompagnement des mutations ou
économique
il faut structurer les métiers de
l'aménagement du territoire et
développer une ingénierie publique
innovantes décentralisée et écologique
renforcer la mixité sociale dans les
grands centres urbains avec le
renforcement des obligations de la loi
sru il a été posé dans le programme
présidentiel
mais les sanctions prévues sont rarement
effective il est prévu de les renforcer
je peux vous assurer qu'elles seront
désormais appliquées je souhaite aussi
que nous réfléchissions au levier que
constitue les documents d'urbanisme pour
favoriser la planification de la mixité
sociale à l'échelle pertinente et éviter
la ségrégation urbaine
nous avons eu déjà un début de débat à
l'occasion de la ppl 30% mais nous
devons voir plus loin
nous devons aussi refaire la ville
prévoir une place pour ses habitants
pour le geste architectural pour la
conception quartier qui prennent en
charge dès leur conception la logistique
et les services
les relations avec le reste des espaces
urbains comme ruraux en privilégiant les
circuits courts qui s'appuie sur des
réseaux de chaleur intelligent sur le
transport durable par exemple je veux
éviter le risque d'un urbanisme
générique d'une ville sans qualité et
sans identité d'une ville qui se plie
aux solvants impératifs financiers de
rentabilité ou sécuritaires le deuxième
élément majeur c'est de résoudre les
crises du logement parce que c'est le
deuxième volet de ce grand ministère
c'est la politique du logement le
logement est un sujet politique mieux
connu et mieux appréhender du débat
politique traditionnelle mais la
politique du logement n'est pas un
complément à la politique d'égalité des
territoires elle est d'abord et avant
tout son moyens pour remplir nos
objectifs
car tous les français et tous les
territoires sont concernés par la
question du logement c'est un des sujets
qui concernent l'intégralité et la
totalité des habitants et des
territoires de notre pays dans les zones
tendues c'est le problème du coût de
l'accès au logement qui est posée et des
conséquences qui en découlent sur
occupation
sa vive réduit au minimum listes
d'attentes interminables pour accéder au
parc social et en parallèle exploitation
de la situation par les marchands de
sommeil qui profitent de la captivité
des ménages dans le parc privé
saturation des capacités d'hébergement
et je sais que la situation dans
certaines métropoles aujourd'hui sur ces
questions est très difficile mais dans
les zones plus détendu ça a aussi été
évoquée à l'occasion du débat tout à
l'heure
les problèmes sont d'une autre nature
mais il existe aussi dégradation du parc
faute d'investissements précarité
énergétique problématique de
l'adaptation des logements au
vieillissement de la population
les sujets sont nombreux ces crises sont
d'abord le résultat d'un monde qui a
changé les inégalités la pauvreté la
précarité au travail ont explosé les
compositions familiales ont évolué le
vieillissement de la population
s'accentue
le modèle français du logement repensez
à la fin des années 70 ne correspond
plus à cette réalité
il faut désormais l'adapter en
profondeur tout en répondant à l'urgence
d'améliorer les conditions de vie des
français pour y parvenir trois défis
majeurs doivent être relevés
le premier le plus important sans lequel
aucune amélioration durable ne sera
possible c'est le défi de l'offre j'ai
parlé de la mobilisation des terrains
j'ai parlé aussi longuement des élus
volontaires et des maires bâtisseurs qui
nous faut soutenir
j'ai parlé également mais peut-être que
nous aurions nous aurons l'occasion d'y
revenir dans le débat de la place des
investisseurs privés qu'il faut stimuler
de manière intelligente
il existe des investisseurs privés
raisonnable soucieux d'investir leur
argent dans une cause utile et qu'il
faut soutenir pour permettre le
développement de logements à coût
abordable
le deuxième défi important concernant le
logement est celui de l'habitat
écologique
vous savez déjà évidemment que le
bâtiment constitue l'un des premiers
secteurs de consommation d'énergie en
france
c'est donc un secteur d'économie
gigantesque mais c'est aussi un secteur
d'emploi durables et non délocalisables
tout aussi important et nous devons
inventer et soutenir les savoir faire
artisanaux et industriels capables de
relever ce défi la rénovation thermique
l'objectif annoncé par le président de
la république est de doter d'une perf en
fermant performance technique de qualité
un million de logements par an c'est un
chantier pharaonique mais c'est aussi en
chantier nécessaire et dans le contexte
de crise que connaît le secteur du
bâtiment et des travaux publics c'est un
chantier absolument indispensable pour
pouvoir mettre en place une politique
d'investissement qui répondent à des
besoins d'emploi très important dans
notre pays et ce plan national de
performance technique sera conçu dans ce
sens en collaboration très étroite et
nous avons déjà commencé à y travailler
avec delphine batho je souhaite
également qu'un chantier de grande
ampleur soit ouvert sur la question des
matériaux les hydrocarbures ne sont pas
la seule ressource rare une réflexion
approfondie doit être menée pour mieux
recycler mieux réutiliser les matériaux
de construction les filières d'éco
matériaux notamment la filière bois
doivent être structurées et mise en
place en lien étroit avec les
collectivités territoriales
on ne construit pas dans le
languedoc-roussillon comme on construit
en franche comté et les solutions
pertinentes varieront d'une région à
l'autre
cela sera ma méthode dans tous les
chantiers que je mènerai des politiques
avec un enjeu national mais des
modalités de mise en oeuvre locales
adaptées aux contextes locaux
le troisième défi qui s'impose à nous de
la façon la plus urgente c'est celui de
l'accès au logement construire 500 mille
logements par an est une absolue
nécessité chacun l'a compris mais encore
faut-il que les français aient les
moyens d'accéder à ces nouveaux
logements lorsque le marché perd ses
repères lorsque les le nom loyers
atteignent des niveaux qui étrangle le
pouvoir d'achat des français
il est de notre devoir de les encadrer
nous sommes en train de le faire le
décret d'urgence qui sera sans doute
effectifs même plus que sans doute qui
sera effectif à compter du 1er août est
une étape dans une volonté d'une loi qui
sera largement débattue
évidemment au parlement mais avec
l'ensemble des acteurs que ce soit les
associations de consommateurs les
associations de locataires mais
également les associations de
propriétaires et les professionnels de
l'immobilier pour permettre que la loi
de 1989 soit revue pour l'instant nous
nous appuyant sur une disposition
particulière de celle-ci et qu'elle
rebaptise des rapports entre
propriétaires et locataires nous
rendrons évidemment ça 10
missions effectives celle d'un
manquement et je le dis d'un encadrement
souple et durable des loyen des loyers
en lien avec les collectivités
parce que nous mettrons en place un
réseau d'observatoires des loyers sur
l'ensemble des principales
agglomérations en lien avec les
collectivités locales
l'objectif vous l'avez compris c'est de
travailler à la construit à la
constitution d'un véritable service
public du logement parce qu il est
inacceptable qu'un demandeur de logement
social aujourd'hui est à suivre un
véritable parcours du combattant
administratif pour obtenir un logement
comme s'y est engagé le président la
république je souhaite une réforme en
profondeur des procédures d'attribution
des logements sociaux
le dispositif refondu devra être plus
simple plus lisible plus juste au
service des de l'ensemble des demandeurs
de logement parce que cette politique du
logement dont doit se faire pour tous
mais aussi au service des plus exclus et
des plus fragiles encore plus
vulnérables avec l'approfondissement de
la crise économique pour les plus
fragiles ceux qui sont mal logées ou qui
vivent dans la rue il faut que les
dispositifs de veille sociale de mise à
l'abri et d'hébergement soit rénové de
manière à accompagner ces personnes dans
la continuité la volonté du gouvernement
est claire l'état doit se donner les
moyens d'appliquer le principe d'accueil
inconditionnel la politique d'accueil et
d'hébergement doit être orienté vers le
logement dans l'esprit de la conférence
de consensus donnait au niveau européen
en 2010 il est nécessaire aussi d'agir
en prévention notamment sur la question
des expulsions et je souhaite mener un
travail approfondi avec les bailleurs
sociaux qui doivent agir dès le premiers
impayés auprès de leurs locataires pour
éviter des situations sociales très
dégradé évidemment que notre objectif ne
va être ne peut être de résoudre toutes
les difficultés et ceci en quelques mois
mais moins mis à la rue un meilleur
accès au logement
un dispositif d'hébergement efficace qui
protègent les personnes et renforce
l'accès au logement doit être au service
d'une politique du logement ambitieuse
et juste parce que l'accès du lot
logement c'est rendre enfin effectif le
droit au logement opposable c'est à dire
faire en sorte que chacun et chacune
dispose d'un vrai lieu de vie et habite
dans un logement de qualité adaptée à
ses besoins et à ses aspirations ça
n'est pas une utopie
c'est une condition nécessaire pour
pouvoir se construire sur
les autres plans économiques sociaux et
familier et familiaux mesdames les
sénatrices monsieur les sénateurs
avaient compris cette feuille de route
et dans ce vaste et ambitieuse j'ai fait
le choix de la présenter de manière
exhaustive devant vous parce que le
projet n'est pas mince c'est celui de
donner à la république l'occasion de
permettre à chacun et chacune de
retrouver sa place son territoire ou son
espace dans notre pays de donner un sens
nouveau est nécessaire à la promesse
d'égalité qui fondent notre projet nous
aurons à coeur et ce sera vraiment mon
cas ni de fermer les yeux sur toutes les
réalités qui constitue notre pays ni de
renoncer ou de reculer au nom du
réalisme compris d' avance parce que oui
la tâche est ardue mais j'ai la
conviction que c'est là que se joue une
part de notre avenir démocratique à
toutes et tous et la préservation d'un
avenir durable pour l'ensemble de nos
territoires
je vous remercie même la ministre merci
merci bravo
alors écoutez les questions ont fusé et
je vous propose pour vous laisser
respirer qu'on donne tout de suite la
parole donc à ceux qui sont inscrits au
fur et à mesure de votre allocution et
que vous puissiez peut-être répondre par
groupes de questions
si vous le souhaitez ou question après
question donc le premier à s'être
inscrits c'est monsieur hervé morin
attend la parole merci monsieur le
président madame la ministre vous avez
présenté un exposé effectivement très
concret je reviendrai naturellement pas
sur tous les sujets que vous avez
évoquées mais j'aimerais parler plus
spécifiquement de la question de
l'aménagement du territoire qui est au
coeur des préoccupations du sénat qui a
une vocation toute particulière a
représenté comme vous le savez les
collectivités et par là même des
territoires j'étais pendant plusieurs
années membre de la majorité mais ça ne
m'a pas empêché de regretter de dire
publiquement qu'en matière d'aménagement
du territoire il n'y avait plus de
pilote dans l'avion
donc je partage un certain nombre de
constats que vous avez pu dresser la
difficulté maintenant pour reprendre le
titre d'un rapport que nous avons
adoptée ici même les dernières à
l'unanimité s'est passé de la parole aux
actes et donc
je le dis très clairement je pense qu'on
a exprimé au nom de mes collègues du
groupe de l'union centriste
nous serons tout à fait prêts à soutenir
tout ce qui pourra aller dans dans le
sens d'une amélioration de l'aménagement
du territoire est naturellement à
souligner les actions qu'ils n'iraient
pas nous nous semble-t-il dans le bon
sens j'aurais évoqué deux sujets sur
lesquels vous vous êtes intervenu et qui
sont importants en matière d'aménagement
du territoire
d'autant plus que comme vous l'avez
souligné on a beaucoup travaillé ces
sujets le premier c'est celui de
l'aménagement numérique des territoires
vous avez à juste titre souligné que
c'était quelque chose de tout à fait
essentiel en termes économiques en
termes de qualité de vie en termes
d'accès à la culture en termes d'accès
au commerce d'accès aux services publics
services publics sur lequel j'ai
beaucoup insisté
et aussi en matière de développement
durable parce que le numérique permet de
comme vous le savez mieux que moi de
réaliser un certain nombre d'économies
en terme de déplacement alors
aujourd'hui ils prennent la république
après des objectifs ambitieux puisqu'il
nous promet le très haut débit pour tous
à échéance de 10 ans c'est mieux que son
prédécesseur qu'il avait proposé à
échéance de 2015 mais l'objectif est
tout aussi ardue à à tenir
d'autant plus que parler de très haut
débit à un certain nombre d'élus qui
dans leur territoire n'ont même pas de
haut débit c'est quelque chose qui
parfois passe assez mal et et le très
haut débit la mise en place ou l'arrivée
du très haut débit aujourd'hui en tout
cas ne fait qu'accentuer une fracture
numérique puisque gré des territoires
sur lesquels effectivement on a des
connexions à très haut débit et d'autres
sur lesquels on a toujours rien donc le
terme égalité des territoires prend
vraiment tout son sens sur sur ce sujet
et sur la mise en place du très haut
débit voulu par le président de la
république
on est dans une situation aujourd'hui
qui est un état qui est totalement
absent du sujet des opérateurs qui vont
et on peut pas leur en faire grief ces
entreprises privées qui vont uniquement
ou c'est rentable donc au milieu soit
vous avez des collectivités qui sont
actives qui sont dynamiques qui ont la
volonté qui ont les moyens qu'ils ont
les compétences et il se passe des
choses
soit c'est pas le cas il se passe rien
et on a véritablement une inégalité
terrible des territoires
je crois que encore une fois si on veut
atteindre l'objectif fixé par après la
république ce que je souhaite il faut
vraiment changer de braquet et il faut
être capable je les dis à votre collègue
fleur pellerin je le redirai ici quand
elle viendra d'une dizaine de jours il
faut être capable de passer outre un
lobby très important qui existe dans ce
pays en matière de numérique et
j'aimerais savoir sur ce point de se sur
ce sujet si le gouvernement entend
inscrire à l'ordre du jour de
l'assemblée nationale la proposition de
loi qui a été adopté par le sénat le 15
février
et dernier point rapide pour ne pas
monopoliser la parole vous avez évoqué
la question des déserts médicaux
c'est effectivement un sujet sur
lesquels on s'est mis au travail sous la
présidence
notre collègue fichés et je crois que
sur ce point là on sera en situation je
suis rapporteur de ce groupe de travail
de faire des propositions à la fin de
l'année j'espère qu'elles seront
examinés qu'attention par le
gouvernement mais ce que je vais juste
vous dire par rapport à votre remarque
sur le temps d'accès je crois que c'est
encore plus important en matière
médicale
c'est pas le temps d'accès c'est le
temps pour obtenir un rendez vous parce
que quand vous attendez six mois sept
mois huit mois 9 mois pour avoir
rendez-vous comme ça existe aujourd'hui
que la spécialiste
vous avez le temps d'avoir votre santé
qui s'aggrave de manière tout à fait
rimer diable voilà ce que je
voulez-vous dire la main ministre
peut-être pourrez-vous m'a apporté
quelques éléments notamment par rapport
à la proposition de loi sur le numérique
adoptée en février
merci je vous demande d'être plus concis
et d'essayer de poser la question on a
tous certainement la possibilité de
s'exprimer si chacun fait un effort
la deuxième question donc c'est michel
teston qui s'est inscrit merci monsieur
le président madame la ministre de
questions que je vais essayer de
présenter très brièvement la première
ont rejoint les préoccupations qui ont
été exprimées par hervé maurey et c'est
la question de savoir comment le
gouvernement entend faire évoluer le
plan national très haut débit qui fait
pour l'instant la part très belle trop
belle aux opérateurs et qui minimisent
finalement le rôle des collectivités
territoriales
donc nous avons fait des propositions
notamment lors de l'examen du texte
auquel hervé maurey affaires du jura
l'instant deuxième question
elle concerne l'accès aux services
publics
je voudrais rappeler que avec comme
premiers signataires jean jacques lozach
erronée nicoud le groupe socialiste du
sénat avait déposé au printemps 2011 une
proposition de loi visant à instaurer un
nouveau pacte territorial et à l'époque
la majorité
2 du sénat ce n'était pas la même
qu'aujourd'hui avait renvoyé ce texte en
commission le 30 juin 2011
simplement ce que je voulais dire c'est
que l'intérêt de cette proposition là
c'est qu'elle prévoit une nouvelle
organisation de l'offre des services
publics et des services au public qui
sont basées sur des questions finalement
de distance et/ou de temps qu'ils sont
minimaux d'accès pour les divers
services publics et donc je voulais
simplement savoir si dans votre prise en
compte du problème de l'accès de
l'égalité d'accès aux services publics
vous pouvez vous appuyer sur les
propositions de cette proposition de loi
d'accord alors madame renée nicoux oui
madame la ministre je crois qu'on ne
peut que à gré tout ce que vous avez pu
dire dans votre proposé dans vos
propositions je crois qu'on est tous là
en attente par rapport aux services
publics notamment
et vous savez quand creuse puisque je
suis sénateur de la creuse
les services publics ont été très
malmené et le département a été un temps
tête de pont des revendications pour le
maintien des services publics et c'est
la raison pour laquelle avec mon
collègue jean jacques lozach nous avions
déposé ici au sénat une proposition de
loi qui visait à élaborer un certain
nombre de critères pour répondre à ses
besoins et en terme de temps d'accès et
non pas en termes de distance comme cela
existe parfois ou en termes de nombre
d'élèves pour des classes par exemple
pour éviter les suppressions de classes
notamment dans les zones de montagne
alors moi j'aurai une question par
rapport à la santé puisque chaque
territoire fait des efforts en termes de
maison de santé pluridisciplinaire de
manière à répondre aussi bien qu'ils le
peuvent
aux problèmes qu'ils rencontrent en
revanche sera t-il y aura-t-il une des
mesures particulières en termes de
numerus clausus quant à la formation des
médecins puisque on s'aperçoit qu'il ya
quand même de ce point de vue là un
certain nombre de deux questions qui se
posent et de problème alors je sais bien
que vous n'avez pas pouvoir me répondre
là puisque ce sera davantage du ressort
du ministre de la santé
mais ce sont des questions que nous nous
posons sur le terrain vous avez aussi
abordé le problème de la restauration
dans le bâtiment et notamment ce qui
concerne l'énergie se pose la question
de la formation puisque dans les
établissements de formation il y as
besoin de de trouver de nouvelles voies
et de nouvelles formations sont à
élaborer pour que les jeunes qui sortent
de nos établissements scolaires
d'enseignement technique ou enseignement
professionnel soit préparée aussi pour
pouvoir en entrant dans les entreprises
mettre en oeuvre de nouvelles techniques
qui ont mais ça veut dire aussi
formation de formateurs puisqu'on
s'aperçoit que dans les entreprises
elles mêmes le problème et rencontrer
actuellement parce que la qualité du
travail rendu par ces entreprises n'est
pas bonne parce que la formation n'a pas
été faite en temps voulu
et enfin je termine terminerai par cela
vous avez parlé de zonage
alors il y avait effectivement des des
zonages qui existe actuellement et je me
ferais si l'interprète des zones de
montagne puisque je pense vous avez été
destinataire d'un courrier de la part
des élus de la montagne qui font appel
au ministre de l'égalité des territoires
pour que soient prises en compte les
spécificités de la montagne qui
rejoignent celles des campagnes de la
ruralité mais de manière beaucoup plus
approfondis puisque la au problème des
distances en ajoutent les problèmes de
la géographie et de la topographie qui
accentue les difficultés donc un certain
nombre de je vais pas citer tous les
points qui sont dénoncées dans ce
courrier mais la nécessité de prendre en
compte les zones de montagne qui
bénéficie d'une loi spécifique de 1985
oui mais je titille hommes
merci monsieur le président mais chaque
collègue madame la ministre
merci d'abord pour votre exposé très
précis et qui va bien dans le sens de ce
que nous souhaitons un état stratège
vous l'avais dit dans une france
décentralisée mais une france diverse et
je pense que nous devons nous au sénat
qui sommes de représentants des
territoires assumer le fait que nous ne
pouvons pas gérer le pays de la même
façon si nous sommes si nous habitons en
zone urbaine dans des grandes métropoles
ou si nous habitons en zone rurale et ce
choix là que vous allez présenter madame
la ministre
j'aurais vraiment vous remercier parce
que c'est essentiel pour la survie de
nos territoires ruraux essentiel pour la
cohésion territoriale vous l'avez dit il
faut absolument mettre des moyens et des
les villes en difficulté comme les
quartiers en difficulté mais également
ne pas oublier ces zones
où la population lors des dernières
élections s'est largement abstenus ou a
largement voté à l'extrême droite
ces zones qui se sentent oubliés parce
que c'est les habitants n'arrivent pas à
vivre il n'y a pas de service pas de
service public
ils sont obligés de prendre leur voiture
pour aller travailler lorsqu'ils ont du
travail
ils sont agriculteurs et ne gagnent pas
leur vie bref penser à l'ensemble des
territoires
alors nous sommes d'accord pour dire que
il faut à la fois mettre fin à larger bp
est à la fois comme vous l'avez dit
faire en sorte que les services publics
soient présents sur tout le territoire
et moyens vocable que nous pourrions
soutenir qu'ils seraient unis statu quo
ni déménagement du territoire
nous sommes d'accord aujourd'hui pour
dire que les services publics ne peuvent
pas être rendus de la même façon en 2012
quand et qu'il y a vingt ans mais en
même temps l'efficacité ne peut pas
toujours être le déménagement du
territoire nos potes ne pourrions nous
pas plutôt que de délocaliser des agents
du service public
délocalisée du travail des villes pour
aller en zone rurale il ya des exils ya
des expérimentations qui sont faites et
qui me semble assez intéressante
deuxième proposition il existe dans nos
villes des contrats urbains de cohésion
sociale
ne pourrions nous pas envisager des
contrats ruraux de cohésion territoriale
qui serait sur la base de ce qui se
passe en ville en zone rurale en zone
périurbaine et danse et danse dans ce
cadre de ces contrats où il ya des
gagnants gagnants où il faut s'appuyer
sur les collectivités locales qui innove
qui font beaucoup de choses pour le pour
la défense et la promotion des services
publics
arriver à faire en sorte comme ça a été
dit avant moi je n'y reviens pas que sur
un territoire à une demi-heure voiture
ou à 4000 doit durer bien les services
publics puissent être pu s'être rendu
enfin tout ça ne pourra pas se faire
sans une grande réforme de la fiscalité
c'est pas dans votre portefeuille
ministériel mais la réforme de la
fiscalité locale la fiscalité nationale
et de la fiscalité locale pour ce faire
sera indispensable aujourd'hui on voit
bien que l'exode péri urbain où l'exode
se fait beaucoup parce que la taxe
d'habitation la taxe foncière est moins
cher à 10 km de la ville centre et on se
retrouve avec des villes paupérisée
foncière il dévide paupérisés et des
communes périurbaines qui sont
totalement différentes et enfin vous
avez évoqué de leur mandat même
istres le fait que les régions s'occuper
de l'économie et que les départements
s'occuper du social je pense que nous
avons besoin ensemble le gouvernement et
le sénat et les associant des lui
réaffirmer clairement le fait que toutes
les collectivités locales en la clause
générale de compétence et que les
départements ne peuvent pas se contenter
uniquement de verser des allocations
sociales et de faire de la suite et la
solidarité sociale parce que les
départements sont très en pointe aussi
sur l'économique sur les causes de ce
soit l'économie et des entreprises
d'économie agricole l'économie
touristique et dans le cadre de
l'égalité des territoires légalité des
collectivités locales dans le
développement me semble aussi très
important voilà en tout cas merci
beaucoup madame la ministre parce que
votre votre intervention très complète
montre nous avons beaucoup de pain sur
la planche surtout vous d'ailleurs mais
nous aussi mais surtout que mais nous
aussi j'ai dit mais nous aussi mais que
dans les mois qui viennent nous
pourrions peut-être redessiner une
france plus juste et plus égalitaire
merci merci je vous propose dans la
question du groupe de questions sur remy
cointreau
oui merci c'est le président madame la
ministre
merci de votre exposé c'est vrai sur le
fond on pourrait il souscrire sur sur la
forme
j'avoue que bon vous avez fait un
catalogue assez un peu important on me
dit le catalogue de la redoute mais bon
on espère qu'on va pouvoir
on espère qu'on va pouvoir que vous
allez pouvoir réussir de de mettre en
place
sur la forme on a l'impression quand
même que après votre exposé et rien ne
s'est fait de avant votre arrivée enfin
on a l'impression que finalement vous
arriver que vous allez vous allez
résoudre tous vous allez vous allez
résoudre
vous allez résoudre tous les problèmes
enfin bon jouer c'est quand même faire
fi des actions qui ont été menées et moi
j'aimerais bien avoir un certain nombre
de précisions sur on n'a pas raisonnable
et les zones de revitalisation rurale
elle existe depuis bien longtemps depuis
bien longtemps
même avant le gouvernement juste par
exemple jouer à savoir qu'est ce que
vous allez faire de ces zones de
revitalisation rurale qui ont quand même
apporté un certain de d'aspects positifs
même si tout n'est pas parfait mais dans
dans ce monde tout est perfectible
ensuite sur les pôles de compétitivité
qui ont été un élément structurant pour
les filières quel est le devenir de ces
pôles de compétitivité sur les pôles
d'excellence rurale au sidaction quand
même que tu est importante pour au
niveau national où on a quand même mis
en avant près de près de saint paul avec
les deux vagues où ç'a permis d'être
accélérateur de projets dans un certain
nombre de territoires ruraux
là aussi j'aimerais bien connaître votre
sentiment sur ces sur ses projets
concernant les maisons de services de
pluridisciplinaire où il ya eu une
action qui a été menée quand même depuis
depuis 10 ans lyon n'a pas rien fait
depuis dix ans il ya quand même des
choses qui ont été faites il ya 300
maisons qui sont prévues quand même mais
on veut pluridisciplinaire qui sont
prévus dans les années à venir plus
l'opération plus de services au public
aussi qui va perdre qui devrait
permettre de remettre en place des
services publics et des services à la
population
donc j'aimerais avoir activé vos
sentiments sur tout ce que vous prévoyez
par ce domaine là où ce que vous allez
supprimés et puis le dernier point vous
parler d'égalité des territoires mais
aussi de désenclavement des territoires
et moi je souscris complètement en
termes de numérique de ses hauts débits
de téléphonie mobile également mais en
termes ferroviaire quel est votre
sentiment sur le l'aspect ligne grande
vitesse sur le désenclavement des
territoires pour savoir un petit peu
comment vous voyez les choses dans ce
domaine
merci
de répondre à ces différentes questions
merci dont je revende que la ministre
réponde je voudrais demander à mes
collègues de ne poser aucune question
sinon on n'arrivera pas à faire passer
tous ceux qui sont inscrits avant une
certaine heure donc si vous pouvez
réfléchir à la question
maintenant on me répondra à ce permis
alors d'abord j'ai fait le choix d'avoir
effectivement davantage de propositions
pour que vous puissiez utiliser le terme
catalogue de la redoute plutôt que de ne
pas en avoir ou quelqu'un vous auriez
dit belle formule mais creuse et quid
des propositions donc comme il fallait
choisir entre une des deux critiques
j'ai plutôt choisi le trop pour vous
répondre bien sûr que beaucoup de choses
se sont faites simplement je crois que
ça a été évoqué par par monsieur
guillaume sur une vision de ce qui était
une politique d'aménagement du
territoire après la vision très
planificatrice des années 60-70 une
vision ensuite très spécialisa trice
dans les années 80 on est resté dans une
situation je le dis personne en est
individuellement ni micro collectivement
responsables mais d'une d'un certain
renoncement justement à une vision
d'aménagement du territoire et je pense
que la politique que nous devons mener
c'est une politique est sans doute moins
exaltantes parce qu'elles sont moins
planificatrice mais plus nécessaire
parce qu'il s'agit de recoudre les
mailles qui au gré d'un tricot sur
lequel on a tiré d'un côté d'un autre se
sont retrouvés très élargi et qui
consiste aujourd'hui à constater qu'il
ya des zones de nos territoires qui sont
des zones qui sont en situation
difficile en situation difficile aussi
parce que et je le dis l'état parfois
réfléchi sur l'aménagement de tel ou tel
service de façon verticale c'est pour ça
que j'ai cité certaines collectivités
locales ou départements qui ont pu subir
avec des logiques qui veut d'un point de
vue de l'état sur l'aménagement de tel
ou tel service se défend des je pense à
la carte judiciaire où je pense à
d'autres types d'organisation mais qui
rendait vulnérable certains territoires
qui voyait disparaître
quasiment en quelques années ce qu'ils
faisaient la structure même de service
public de ce territoire donc l'état
d'esprit du ministère l'égalité des
territoires c'est bien de renouer avec
une vision d'aménagement qui soit une
vision qui tienne compte à la fois de ce
qui s'est fait pendant les années
précédentes
et aussi que nous sommes trente ans
après le début de la décentralisation et
que l'état n'a plus du tout à jouer le
rôle
planificateur et très décideurs qu'ils
pouvaient avoir mais que les
collectivités locales ont pris de
l'ampleur des responsabilités bien sûr
que les départements les régions assure
bien d'autres missions que leur mission
essentielle est que on sait à quel point
elles sont indispensables je dirai juste
un point faisant le lien avec la
question logement aujourd'hui sans
certaines collectivités locales en
particulier sans certaines régions voire
100 certains départements on aurait
énormément de mal monsieur collomb l'a
rappelé sur le rôle de la communauté
urbaine de l'agglomération de lyon les
choses seraient quasiment impossible
étant donné une part de désengagement de
l'état mais surtout une politique de
soutien au développement de l'offre de
logement locatif social très important
de la part des collectivités locales
donc c'est bien repenser à la fois cette
vision spatiale et aussi cette vision
d'organisation d'un pays qui n'est plus
le même que celui des années 60-70 qu'il
faut réconcilier dans la politique qui
sera menée pour vous répondre très
précisément à certaines de vos questions
sur la question de la couverture
numérique du territoire je pense que un
des moyens pour avancer sur le sujet
c'est bien de mettre tout le monde
autour de la table et c'est la manière
dont nous avons décidé d'y travailler
avec fleur pellerin en mettant les
opérateurs les différents acteurs pour
pousser à une politique équilibrée
chacun le sait ça nécessitera aussi un
investissement de la part des
collectivités locales elles le font déjà
mais aussi de la part de l'état qui est
un investissement significatif est dans
un contexte qui est un contexte
difficile ce sera au final les sénateurs
et les députés qui auront arbitré sur
les choix budgétaires de l'état dans ces
directions mais la volonté est très
forte et nous réfléchissons à la
création d'un comité de pilotage
interministériel pour l'aménagement et
le développement du numérique qui
permettent de mettre l'ensemble des
sujets sur la table on a attiré mon
attention notamment sur la difficulté de
se raccorder notre parfois pour des
petites collectivités locales à des
réseaux déjà existants le long des
grandes voix et en particulier des
autoroutes ou du câblage effectué par la
fibre pour des installations comme le
peuvent être les éoliennes c'est très
important de pouvoir aussi lever les
obstacles juridiques ou administratifs
ou réglementaires qui existent encore
pour favoriser cette couverture du
territoire sur
la question médicale je lirai et chacun
je pense prendra connaissance avec
beaucoup d'attention des propositions
qui seront faites quand je parlais de
temps d'accès c'est un temps qui n'était
pas seulement un temps d'accès physique
au lieu où se trouve la présence
médicale mais c'est bien sûr la
possibilité d'avoir accès tout
simplement et de répondre à ses besoins
mais réfléchir entendent accepte bien
sûr que c'est une réflexion qui s'est
fait et je ferai lien notamment avec ce
qui se passe en zone de montagne
mais c'est la volonté justement de
pouvoir réfléchir à une autre géographie
de l'accès aux services publics qu une
géographie vue secteur par secteur et à
ce titre voilà les échanges que j'ai eus
avec la ministre en charge de la santé
marisol touraine vont dans ce sens
c'est-à-dire d'inclure cette politique
de la santé en lien avec les autres
politiques de services publics de
réfléchir à la possibilité justement de
s'appuyer sur des expériences qui existe
dans certaines dans certaines régions
des expérimentations menées par cette
certaine ars qui permettent si elle
fonctionne et quand elle fonctionne de
pouvoir les étendre plus facilement à
d'autres territoires
donc bien sûr que sur ces questions là
où personne n'a la vérité révélée et où
les risques de blocages peuvent être
importants tout ce qui sera des
expériences déjà validé des travaux
partager et on va dire le résultat d'une
concertation approfondie qui pourra du
coup rendre ces dispositifs plus
opérationnels plus vite seront favorisés
sur la question 2
des pôles de compétitivité des des zones
rurales et des delà du zonage des zones
de revitalisation rurale
je dois vous dire que les premières
consultations que j'ai pu avoir sur ce
sujet donne un résultat assez cocasse si
la situation n'était pas si difficile
c'est à dire que ces zones ne sont plus
adaptés et sont forcément contestée par
beaucoup et que quand il s'agit de poser
la question d'un nouveau zonage chacun
convient que ce sera extrêmement
difficile
c'est toujours cette question c'est
toujours le même débat sur le zonage le
zonage existant n'est pas adaptée mais
s'il faut le refaire on se dit que ça va
être vite compliqué moi j'ai tendance à
penser que quand un zonage n'est pas
adapté surtout quand comme je viens de
le pointer on a répondu à cette absence
de pertinence du zonage par une nouvelle
couche de zonage il serait peut-être
utile d'essayer dans un cadre qui sera à
définir qui associera plus largement
possible les élus mais un zonage plus
global plus simple et dans cette
réflexion qui est la mienne la
simplification du recours aux différents
dispositifs notamment pour les élus
locaux quelque chose d'assez centrale
dans ma réflexion
il y a beaucoup dispositif aujourd'hui
qu'ils ne sont pas mobilisés je pense à
terre certaines aides européennes du
fait de la complexité du fait de
hiérarchie
construite petit à petit qui rendent
l'accès à des dispositifs qui serait
pourtant pertinent de plus en plus
difficile donc il me semble qu'un
travail de simplification sans doute que
c'est peut-être pour certains ministres
moins glorieux que de créer leur propre
dispositif
mais si ma modeste contribution peut
être de faire en sorte qu'ils aient
cette phase de simplification d'un de
deux dispositifs empilés et de zone et
de zonage qui sont parfois continues ou
parfois même sur certaines politiques
quasiment à la limite de la
contradiction je pense que ce sera utile
et je pense que pour ce qui est des
zones de revitalisation rurale c'est
assez nécessaire on sait aussi que hong
hao jours on a je le dis sans polémique
mais met notamment parce que ça a été ça
m'a été dit de manière très ferme par
l'association des maires
d euros que un certain nombre de
dispositifs avaient été rhabillé sans
que des financements nouveaux n'étaient
été créée qu'on a simplement remis du
bol du quai et du papier doré autour de
dispositifs et de financement déjà
existants donc il me semble plus
important qu'on puisse avoir accès le
plus facilement possible au dispositif
mobilisables je pense en particulier aux
fonds européens dont un certain nombre
de zones rurales peuvent bénéficier pour
ce qui est de la montagne
il y à un élément particulier qui est
que nous avons à renouveler le conseil
national de la montagne avant le mois de
novembre au mois de novembre 2012 et que
je souhaite organiser une réunion
d'installation très rapidement à l'issue
de de son renouvellement justement pour
que l'ensemble de ces questions soit
revue à l'aune des politiques déjà
menées et sans doute dans un état
d'esprit qui est celui de considérer que
les territoires de montagne ont une
contribution particulière à l'égalité
des territoires mais sont aussi plus
vulnérable je pense en particulier à des
activités saisonnières que chacun
connaît au dérèglement climatique et qui
me semblerait utile de pouvoir anticiper
des difficultés qui pourraient survenir
pour un grand nombre de ces territoires
de montagne qu'est ce que j'ai oublié de
vous dire ah oui sur la question de
déformations sur les métiers de la
rénovation thermique le premier ministre
on a lui même parlé dans son discours de
politique générale il est absolument
essentiel quand on a un plan d'une telle
ampleur de le faire en lien avec les
professionnels avec les centres de
formation c'est d'ores et déjà le cas
les discussions sont déjà ouvertes
évidemment chacun attend les contours
même du dispositif pour pouvoir
s'insérer avec une vision assez durable
et je les dis sûr j'ai déjà eu
l'occasion de le dire sur la politique
du logement
c'est la même chose pour la politique de
rénovation thermique notre volonté est
de pouvoir présenter un dispositif
pluriannuel qui permettent à des
professionnels de situer dans la durée
je pense en particulier à tous à tout
l'univers et tout le monde du logement
de la construction on sait bien que une
politique parakou est une politique qui
empêche qu elles soient réalisés quel
que soit d'ailleurs sa pertinence parce
que ce sont des opérateurs qui ont
besoin de stabilité dans la durée nous
allons faire en sorte de la leur offrir
bien merci alors ton la parole monsieur
alain bertrand sénateur de la lozère
oui moi jour propres madame la ministre
chaque collège moi je comptais plaidé
l'hyper u réalité il ya la différence
forte
on ne peut pas faire la différence entre
l'urbain c'est par un parti et le rural
et l'urbain et le rural
hellip et rural et je me disais parce
que je suis méfiant avaient tous les
scientifiques les ministres ou les
jeunes et gran de ville ou de paris mais
je savais que vous êtes allé à lozère où
madame la ministre déjà que vous allez
régulièrement je me disais elle
n'apportera aucune réponse à cette
notion d'hyper u khalid et leurs
collègues côté si vous voulez prendre
votre micro est finalement beaucoup de
leurs épouses notamment en parlant de
deux territoires ruraux à faible densité
notamment même disait qu'il y avait des
territoires qui étaient déjà meurtri et
qu'il fallait apporter des réparations
notamment me disant qu'il allait revoir
les zonages donc je m'apprêtais à
plaider sagna vous dire que bob par
exemple pour le trial lozère pour aller
à paris aller-retour ses 18 heures le
téléphone heures il passe pas internet
ça passe pas les échos les gr on en a
pas les universités on an'a pas les
agglomérations et k2 1000 habitants on
en a pas les vies de ces quinze mille
amis targa n'a pas les scanners si on
est malade on n'a pas les spécialistes
on n'a pas les pôles d'excellence ruraux
chers collègues ils ont servi à faire de
la politique pour les copains à deux
parties la zone de revitalisation rurale
on est en train d'en sortir à siffler et
donc sur les propositions que vous avez
faits réparation de solidarité services
publics pour tous et surtout sur
l'ambition au départ parce que vous êtes
au départ de mende a bondi de 5 à moi je
me félicite de votre volontarisme du
fait que vous vouliez donner une
certaine égalité des chances à se
faisaient territoire parce que voyez des
choses qui ne vont pas du tout par
exemple le monde petits départements la
lozère on n'a pas la prime d'aménagement
du territoire vous savez les aides à
finalité régionale ils appellent ça
maintenant c'est complètement
surréaliste et je trouve que la notion
de montagne pour répondre à ma collègue
de la creuse c'est comparable un peu à
la lozère
c'est un peu moins virale mais ses
copains mais j'habitais c'est anna la
creuse là la notion de montagne non plus
ne n'est pas suffisante madame le
ministre madame la ministre pour faire
la différence
il ya des montagnes avec une autoroute à
10 minutes et une grande ville de 5000
habitants avec une université avec
toutes les ressources il faut travailler
la notion d'hyper ruralité comme lotion
discriminante positivement et pour que
vous trouviez les mesures adaptées à
prades en tout cas moi je vous félicite
pour le courage avec lequel vous
attendez à l'ouvragé mais bon bien sûr
je formulerai chaque fois je reviendrai
à la charge sur cette histoire de ces
territoires en souffrance qui ont une
volonté de venir comme vous l'avez dit
qu'ils doivent participer à l'économie
et pour lesquels il faut trouver quelque
chose de nouveau
ces nouveaux ce qu'il faut éviter si
vous reprenez tous les ans à 20 c est
tout ça sortira pas je les fais moi même
le travail cartographique aux prêts à
l'époque auprès de georges frêche précis
de lui démontrer mais au bout d'un
moment les administrations et tous avons
convaincu que j'étais pas assez
intelligent il est arrêté
je suis sûr que vous allez arriver
madame bravo monsieur martial bourquin
j'aurais vous dire aussi bien de la
musique ça fait plaisir d'entendre votre
discours sur l'égalité des territoires
et on a envie de vous aider pour vous
parveniez à ce que justement n'y est
plus et inégalités difficilement
supportables sur nos territoires
on a participé pendant un an au débat
sur l'intercommunalité des cdc
on a voulu parfois à court chez accouché
d'une intercommunalité au forceps ça
marche pas ces choses là et je me
demande s'il ferait pas parce que
maintenant dans quasiment une carte on a
plus de zone blanche concernant
l'intercommunalité
s'il ne faudrait pas aborder maintenant
des schémas directeurs d'aménagement du
territoire dans chaque
est ce parce qu'ils soient rural ou
urbain avec une volonté d'avoir des
services publics dans chaque espace
rural ou urbain et surtout lorsqu il y a
retrait de service public ne jamais
mettre les élus devant les le fait
accompli mais à voir le débat auparavant
ça c'est le premier point
deuxième point je pense que la dréal les
services publics de l'état ont changé de
nature avec la rgpp on a eu
concentration de l'équipement dans la
ville capitale et les dd a qui étaient à
côté des élus ruraux souvent ne sont
plus à leur côté je peux vous dire que
cette aide ce conseil au cerveau aux
élus ruraux aux élus en général fait
cruellement défaut et en même temps
cette dréal voyez par monsieur sûr je
suis sur un projet une commande en
pleine ruralité des communes se sont
mises ensemble deux intercommunalités et
met en place une zone artisanale de
grande qualité respectant et la dréal
hélas n'est plus un facilitateur de
projets elle arrive elle agit souvent en
juge de paix et je me demande si on
arrête la rgpp s'il ne faudrait pas
repenser les services de l'état aux
côtés des élus plutôt que deux parfois
les gêner à mettre en place leur projet
ça c'est une vraie question parce que si
on n'a pas un ingénieur territorial
si on n'a pas c'était nos élus
inévitablement ça risque nos grandes nos
grandes idées risque de rester lettre
morte
dernière chose votre collègue anne marie
escoffier a terminé une mission très
importante sur la tp et il faut penser
aussi aux territoires industriels et les
propositions du sénat pour justement
éviter les graves problèmes qu'engendre
la suppression de la tp et la mise en
place d autres taxes notamment la cvae
amènerait à rééquilibrer les moyens des
territoires je prends un exemple la
région parisienne avait peu de taxe
professionnelle la cvae à doubler
quasiment sais ce que c'est le constat
que fait et c'est une mission qui est
complètement pluraliste 1 est ce qu'on
ne devrait pas rééquilibré faire en
sorte que les territoires du ciel qui
payent le prix fort avec un taux de
chômage élevé qui ont besoin
d'équipement du territoire on
rééquilibre les territoires mais aussi
on rééquilibre la ruralité sont des
vraies questions sont des outils des
leviers qui vont permettre d'aboutir au
projet que vous avez qui est un bon
projet auquel ont souscrit totalement
merci monsieur foucher madame nominés
simplement révoquer un point il ya eu
l'expérience ya quelques années
l'expérience borloo soit la maison de
l'emploi qui en fait n'ont pas très bien
fonctionner d'une manière générale
malgré qu'il ya eu des crédits
importants quitte à disposition pour le
faire se sont mis en place dans certains
secteurs dans le mien dans d'autres des
maisons de service public
aujourd'hui qui sont des maisons de
proximité et dans lesquels il ya des
cellules pour l'emploi il ya des
cellules rural il ya pôle emploi un
petit peu non ma question qu'il soit
voulais vous poser les très simple c'est
pour l'emploi parti s'est passé
interministériel pour l'emploi
participent peu dans ces maisons de
service public il est plutôt cantonnées
dans des villes plus importantes
ces maisons services publics sont
implantés dans la ruralité dans les
petites villes
est ce que vous envisagez de demander à
ce que pôle emploi ça plus délocaliser
premier point deuxième point ces maisons
services publics sont financés par les
départements par les régions par les
pays par l'intercours mais l'état ne
participe plus et ne veut plus
participer et c'est très difficile à
faire fonctionner est ce que vous
envisagez de votre côté incité est ce
que l'état soit partenaire financier
aussi merci ce charles revêt oui merci
monsieur président
hmm hmm nice c'est un vaste programme
que vous avez présentée et je ne dirai
comme mon ami rémy pointereau on vous
souhaite que vous puissiez le mener à
bien ne jamais donner quelques lignes
directrices si j'ai bien noté réparation
voir des territoires meurtri resterait
assez des rencontres et territoires
s'assurer un permanence des services
nous avons pris une formule j'espère que
je vais bien ne t donné à tous les
habitants la possibilité de leur choix
de vie c'est bien ce que j'ai entendu à
ce bon oui je veux que moi j'ai
peut-être noté différemment dire la même
chose
je pense que ça va dans le même sens me
semble-t-il bien alors moi mais ma
question si vous voulez 12
sur le principe c'est c'est très bien
mais mais il ya deux deux éléments
importants
je vais dire d'une boutade je
m'interroge et si vous n'aviez pas gagné
jackpot hier soir parce que tout ça ça
va nécessiter des financements
importants
ça se fait pas et dans le contexte
présent comment allez vous faire pour
assurer le financement et deuxième point
mais j'ai bien entendu j'ai à l'esprit
ce que disait gérard collomb cet
après-midi et mireille mireille schurch
dans son intervention et notre collègue
bourquin tweets sur le terrain il
faudrait peut-être que les services de
l'état soient plus attentifs aux ce que
soit faire c'est ce que les élus sont
sur le terrain et que quelque part ils
viennent pas dans les scot tous les
autres de documents pour imposer leur
démarche au prétexte qu'ils appliquent
tel ou tel texte et moi ce que je
souhaiterais c'est que vous donniez des
instructions extrêmement forte et
précise aux services de l'état sur le
terrain pour leur dire voilà ce que j'ai
dit et voilà ce que vous devez appliquer
sur le terrain
il nous reste une dernière question pour
un groupe de 10 madame mireille cherche
merci donc nous nous réjouissons du
ministère de l'exil de l'égalité des
territoires on espère que ce d'abord ce
ministère un grand chantier comme vous
venez de l'énoncé madame la ministre et
nous espérons qu'il va réussir
j'ai plusieurs questions plus le plus
serré d'abord sur la fracture numérique
lorsque nous avons débattu du de la loi
sur la fracture numérique
la france est divisée en trois zones les
zones très denses sur laquelle les
opérateurs tranquillement investissent
et il n'y a pas besoin de contribution
de personnes les zones intermédiaires et
les zones très peu denses là c'est la
collectivité qui met l'argent à la poche
est ce que madame la ministre nous
allons aller vers une contrainte des
opérateurs privés
en tout cas une obligation qui ferait
qu' on met un pot commun il verse une
partie de leurs dividendes qu'ils
génèrent dans les zones denses pour les
répartir sur les zones moins denses
espèce de péréquation financière mais
demandé aux opérateurs privés est ce que
l'état va se faire autoritaire en
quelques mots sur cette question
deuxième sujet oui nous avons besoin
d'un état attentif
alors concernant les déserts médicaux
comment là aussi alors dans de nombreux
cantons zh visite on inaugure des
maisons médicales de santé et le ont me
dis bah on attend le médecin ou en
attente kiné on en a pas et pourtant les
maisons médicales de santé qu'on
inaugure son magnifique c'est de
l'argent des collectivités territoriales
dans le département de l'allier le
département donne une bourse d'études
aux étudiants de troisième cycle et ça
ne suffit pas on a une population qui
est dans l'insécurité et ça génère des
votes extrêmes sur ces sujets sains
sensibles que sont la santé dont est ce
qu'on va réussir à contraindre le corps
médical pour une meilleure répartition
territoriale je vois pas comment on peut
faire autrement à l'image des
pharmaciens troisième sujet
je prends la casquette massif central et
je parlerai au nom de ce grand
territoire qui se sent abandonné quelque
peu méprisé alors je donne un exemple
sur les tgv
madame la ministre sur je sais que le
tgv a pas votre faveur mais quand même
sur l'ensemble du territoire national
cinq capitales régionales ne sont pas
raccordées au tgv toulouse on peut
penser que c'est bientôt le cas 3
je voulais site orléans clermont ferrand
et limoges dans le grand massif central
ça fait beaucoup pour le massif central
et si vous regardez la carte tgv on
évite très soigneusement le massif
central qui se trouve donc enclavés de
la grande vitesse
alors je vous pose la question est ce
que vous allez nous aider les habitants
de ceux de cette grande région pour
qu'enfin on peut on puisse percer ce
massif central qui n'est pas une zone de
montagne insurmontable et impénétrable
et qui pourrait permettre des liaisons
plus que plus de nord-sud
elle existe déjà mais surtout est-ouest
et là je parle aussi du fret ferroviaire
alors ça ça vous tient à coeur n'y a pas
de lignes transversales pertinente est
ouest je termine par deux questions
madame la ministre sur le logement est
ce que l'on va interdire est ce que vous
allez interdire dans est en tout cas en
discuter dans la prochaine de loi sur le
logement les expulsions pour les
prioritaires dalo est ce que c'est une
volonté forte on l'attend vous le savez
est enfin sur les ce qu'on appelle le
logement décent puisqu'un décret un
décret eu à ce jour qui dit qu'un
logement décent c'est neuf mètres carré
or tous les acteurs du logement disent
non c'est au moins 14 mètres carrés donc
il ya un sujet quand même assez facile à
régler puisque il peut être réglé par
dispositions réglementaires et vous en
avez en votre qualité vous en avez la
possibilité allez vous engager la
refonte de ce décret sur les neuf mètres
carrés qui permettrait d'aller jusqu'au
14 mètres carrés pour définir ce qu'on
appelle logement décent merci merci
daniel dubois
merci président madame la ministre trois
questions une qui vous concerne très
directement
vous avez déclaré devant les dréal que
l'opération habiter mieux ré vers elle
ne fonctionnait pas du tout ou très
lentement
donc il y avait des expositions qui
avait été prise par la nar elles
gouvernement précédent est ce que vous
envisagez de les poursuivre ou au
contraire de les modifier non et dans
quel sens pour que ça aille mieux
2 deuxième deuxième question on a eu un
débat sur le logement tout à l'heure je
pense qu'il était effectivement
intéressant moi j'ai terminé j'aurais
sur la problématique des territoires
ruraux
puisqu'on parle beaucoup des zones
tendues mais moi je crains après si les
politiques continuent au niveau des
territoires ruraux en termes de
politique du logement que l'on crée un
véritable effet de ciseaux pour les et
pour les territoires ruraux qui ont
engagé des dépenses devraient pour que
les services publics restent parce qu'il
y aura plus d'habitants et que l'on est
on préparera tout simplement gérer des
zones murray réservé aux indiens à
quelques indiens qui resteront encore
sur ces territoires
donc moi j'aimerais avoir une position
de votre part assez clair par rapport à
cela
est-ce qu'on peut encore construire sur
les territoires ruraux et est ce que les
dréal non pas des ordres pour passer
d'une approche de l'urbanisme à une
approche numérique à une approche
numérique et red aux constructions sur
les territoires troisième question enfin
vous êtes ministre met certes mais vous
êtes vous avez été aussi président
aurait donc d'un parti vert je voulais
avoir votre position sur le canal à
grand gabarit est ce que vous êtes
favorable ou pas au canal à grand
gabarit
parce qu'on a encore en mémoire si vous
les verrez il y avait des projets qui
ont été arrêtés il n'y a pas si
longtemps
merci mais non merci voulu alors d'abord
se méfier des a priori monsieur le
sénateur de la nauze lozère a compris
c'est une utilisatrice assidu du cévenol
feu le cévenol qui vous le dit mais donc
je vais répondre à plusieurs de vos
points effectivement c'est un projet
ambitieux mais c'est aussi à la hauteur
et je le dis très tranquillement des
besoins c'est à dire que si aujourd'hui
nous considérons que
les choses parte à vau l'eau et qui ne
faut pas essayer de saisir à bras le
corps un certain nombre de ces
problématiques
en tout cas pour moi je pense qu'il y
aurait peu de raison à assumer ce type
de responsabilité je pense que la
responsabilité politique du parlement
dans son ensemble et du gouvernement
aujourd'hui est de saisir ces sujets à
bras le corps de saisir effectivement ce
lien entre les territoires ruraux où il
perd ruraux outre air euro mais aussi de
d'en saisir toutes leurs richesses alors
pour répondre très précisément à vos
questions ce que vous êtes retenu
pendant un quart d'heure mais mon
ancienne étiquette qui n'a ni l'an rien
mes convictions va me conduire à vous
apporter de réponses d'abord les
écologistes n'ont rien contre les grands
projets d'infrastructure par principe
ils ont absolument deux éléments qui les
conduit c'est d'abord leur utilité et
ensuite c'est d'être pragmatique et là
ce n'est plus du tout l'écologiste qui
parle c'est parfaitement la ministre de
ce gouvernement chacun le sait le schéma
national des infrastructures de
transport ses 110 ans d'investissements
publics à la hauteur de l'investissement
actuel
donc tout le monde sait que ce schéma
national ne sera pas réalisée dans les
dix ans qui viennent et c'est pas la
volonté ou l'absence de volonté de qui
que ce soit c'est simplement le réalisme
qui oblige les uns et les autres y
compris ceux d'ailleurs qui l'ont établi
et qui voulait y voir figurer telle ou
telle ligne de tgv ou telle ou telle
grande infrastructure de transport
qu'ils ont d'eux fait assumé donc il
faut se dire les choses avec simplicité
l'intégralité de ce schéma ne pourra pas
se réaliser dans les délais qui ont été
dits pour chacune des infrastructures
prévues
ça c'est le premier élément le de lier
le deuxième élément c'est que dans une
période de difficultés financières comme
celle que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
la responsabilité de l'état dans son
ensemble c'est de prioriser ses
investissements là où ils sont le plus
nécessaires
et ça peut être des investissements
ferrer dans un cas ça peut être des
investissements sur le numérique dans
d'autres cas il faut absolument
réfléchir à la priorisation de ses
investissements et puis à la sobriété de
ceux ci dans une période financière
tendue et et c'est le principe de les
réalités qui m'oblige à dire ça devant
vous c'est ni ma volonté ni mes
convictions c'est simplement sur ces
sujets là la réalité et donc il faut
être capable je crois notamment sur le
réseau de transport et je pense en
particulier aux transports ferrés et ça
commençait à être le cas il faut
s'inquiéter très rapidement de l'état de
ces réseaux qui ne sont pas des réseaux
à grande vitesse pourquoi
parce que si on arrête l'investissement
sur les réseaux secondaires au motif qu
on pourrait avoir une ligne tgv alors le
risque c'est de ne pas avoir de ligne
lgv est d'avoir des réseaux de transport
qui seront des raisons transport
classique tellement dégradée que le
niveau du service qui sera assurée soit
inférieure à la qualité de celui des
années 50
donc je crois qu'il est absolument
nécessaire mais c'est pour ça que je
vous dis je je crois connaître bien ces
sujets c'est pour ça que je vous dis que
s'il faut orienter une partie des
investissements qui sont forcément moins
importants que ceux dont on a pu
disposer dans le passé il est pour
justement ne pas perdre le niveau de
service qui existe aujourd'hui sur sur
sur ces sujets là ça me paraît très
important est la question qui est posée
par le canal à grand gabarit est une
question qui se pose sur d'autres sujets
et qui a été posée très largement au
sein du gouvernement c'est la question
des partenariats publics privés ou des
collectivités locales de toute étiquette
de toutes obédiences se réveille dans
des situations un peu douloureuse parce
que les signatures de certains contrats
je pense notamment y compris à des
infrastructures de santé recèlent les
surprises extrêmement douloureuse
financièrement pour les collectivités
locales qui ont participé à ce type de
contrat et que l'expérimentation qui
serait celle d'un canal avec un
investissement très important dans ce
cadre-là pourrait laisser à penser qu'il
ya une source d'inquiétudes financières
en tout cas je les ai entendu s'exprimer
sur toutes les deux la part d'élus issus
de toutes sensibilités politiques et je
pense qu'il est important de tirer un
bilan de ces questions avant de se
relancer dans des projets de ce type je
le dis parce qu'avec la franchise qui
met légendaire j'ai constaté quand même
que les uns et les autres j'ai reçu
l'ensemble des associations d'élus sont
capables de dire des choses assez assez
similaire pour répondre sur les
intercommunalités monsieur bourquin bien
sûr que le forceps ne marche pas mais le
statu quo ne marche pas non plus vous
avez dit avec raison que le
désengagement de certains services de
l'état rendait la situation de certaines
collectivités locales délicate je pense
aux petites communes rurales qui assume
seule la compétence urbanisme et qui
n'ont plus les services d'appui de
l'état la situation devient de plus en
plus délicate je suis consciente de ça
simplement
me dois de dire que le chemin vers
l'intercommunalité et vers l'assurance
de ses services supports dans un cadre
intercommunal est un chemin pour lequel
on ne reviendra pas en arrière c'est à
dire que la logique de la
décentralisation et notamment de cette
compétence vise forcément à ce qu'elle
soit pleinement assurée par les
collectivités locales qui en ont la
charge et donc il est absolument
nécessaire que ce chemin là se
poursuivent et que je crois qu'un outil
qui commence à avoir fait ses preuves
c'est le schéma de cohérence
territoriale pris pleinement en main par
les collectivités locales comme un outil
qui mobilise l'ensemble des
collectivités locales autour d'un projet
d'un projet de territoire partagé où le
travail entre les scot
ce trail d'intel scott se fait de mieux
en mieux je pense qu'il faut essayer
d'aboutir à une couverture de l'ensemble
du territoire français de ce type
d'outils qui permet aussi une bien
meilleure contractualisation entre
l'état et les collectivités locales dans
le cadre d'un projet partagé par
l'ensemble des collectivités locales
donc on est très jeu serait très
attentive à soutenir cette démarche de
scott et à faire aussi en sorte que les
scot deviennent plus robuste parce
qu'ils sont aujourd'hui juridiquement
très vulnérable et que dans le travail
que nous aurons à mener que j'évoquais
tout à l'heure pendant le débat sur la
ppl 30% cette question soient aussi
prises en compte pour améliorer pour
aider tous les élus locaux qui ont ces
dispositifs de scott qui dont il
constate parfois la vulnérabilité
durable pour des intérêts qui sont des
intérêts très particuliers
sur la question très précise des maisons
de l'emploi et de la délocalisation de
pôle emploi je pense qu'il faut qu'on
travaille sur un dispositif je parlais
de l'accès aux services publics et de
l'accès à un service d'accueil une de
nos réflexions à ce stade est de
considérer que un agent d'accueil qui
assure les services publics peut être
celui qui oriente vers d'autres types de
dispositifs mais que le contact est un
contact qui est un contact humain et qui
est un contact aisé parce qu'il est
physiquement à proximité et que donc il
faut qu'on travaille notamment à la mise
en place d'un dispositif juridique très
aisée dans lequel puce insérée à la fois
les services de l'état et les
différentes collectivités locales pour
l'instant ce dispositif n'existe pas est
devenu à des acrobaties parfois assez
complexe j'ai pu voir effectivement
certaines réalisations ça existe des
départements notamment ont été à
l'initiative de ce type de maison de
service public
mais c'est parfois complexes notamment
pour les services de l'état de s'insérer
dans ce type de dispositif je pense que
c'est vraiment une des 10 et une
difficulté qu'on doit lever très vite
c'est celle ci et nous allons nous y
employer sur la question précise du
logement d'abord nous souhaitons
travailler effectivement sur la capacité
la double capacité contradictoires qui
est donné aux préfets à la fois de
reloger de loger prioritairement les
familles qui bénéficient du dalo est
tout autant que de recourir à la force
publique pour les faire expulser de
logement dans lequel elle se trouve donc
une instruction est en cours de
discussion entre le ministère du
logement en l'occurrence et le ministère
de l'intérieur c'est un sujet qui est un
sujet compliqué c'est un sujet sensible
mais ma détermination celle du ministère
du logement sur le sujet est très grande
et je souhaite que nous aboutissions en
sachant que ça ne résoudra pas une
impasse ce qui est une impasse très
clair c'est à dire 20 mille trente mille
quarante mille demandeurs dalo qui ne
trouvent pas à se loger dans le parc
aujourd'hui pour plusieurs raisons
notamment pour la mobiliser par la
défaite de la mobilisation de l'absence
de mobilisation suffisamment importante
des bailleurs donc nous allons aussi
travailler sur cette question dans le
cadre de la réforme sur les attributions
sur le décret sur le logement décent je
crois qu'il faut se garder du un
dispositif de cette nature qui
risquerait d'aggraver la crise que nous
connaissons je le dis pourquoi parce que
son ont été réalisés depuis des années
les résidences sociales notamment qui
sont d'une taille inférieure avec des
logements de taille inférieure à 14
mètres carrés on peut objectivement
considéré je pense que ce serait un
débat assez long sur la taille minimale
dans lequel on peut considérer qu'il est
descendre vivre mais aujourd'hui la de
manière très pragmatique et tout autant
pragmatique que je vous ai répondu sur
la question des grandes infrastructures
on créerait une situation extrêmement
délicate et sans doute avec le maintien
de locataires de fait sans droit ni
titre dans des logements et voire même
partie du patrimoine à caractère social
qui ne seraient plus habitable ou qui
nécessiterait des investissements
massifs
donc ça ne me paraît pas du tout être
réalisable de manière opérationnelle
assez rapidement même si on peut très
bien considéré que la norme minimale sur
en particulier le patrimoine qui
construit avec l'aide de l'état doit
pouvoir être augmentée sur le programme
habiter mieux
oui je les dis et ce n'est pas un secret
que c'est un programme qui a plus que du
mal à démarrer qu'en revanche il ya une
vraie nécessité donc il sera mis en lien
avec cet objectif très important de la
rénovation thermique d'un million de
logements par an il ya des
expérimentations qui ont été utiles il
ya aujourd'hui visiblement des
difficultés très grande sur le
dispositif sur les dispositifs anna qui
sous couvert de concerts en plis
fication ont été deux fêtes complexifié
et qui n'ont pas été capables de
distribuer l'intégralité des aides et du
budget dont il disposait au regard des
besoins qui sont immenses donc il ya
visiblement une difficulté qu'il faut
lever et nous allons travailler à lever
cette dispute cette difficulté et à
faire en sorte que l'ana remplissent
près pleinement sa mission qui est
absolument nécessaire dans la période
qui vient sur la fracture numérique j'y
reviens vous nous voulons absolument
faire en sorte que nous travaillons sur
l'ensemble de ces questions aujourd'hui
le droit européen permet simplement
qu'ils puissent de rendre possible la
mise en place de réseaux d'initiative
publique à partir du moment les
opérateurs font défaut il ne permet pas
de contraindre des opérateurs à investir
dans des zones où il ne considérait pas
qu'il veuille le faire simplement gelé
d'y mettre l'ensemble des opérateurs
autour de la table avec les
collectivités locales avec l'état peut
permettre de faire avancer un certain
nombre de sujets j'ai parlé aussi de
questions réglementaires qui pourrait
être levé sans grande difficulté qui
pourrait amener pour certains
territoires des solutions plus
rapidement
donc c'est un sujet sur lequel mais vous
aurez l'occasion aussi d'en parler avec
fleur pellerin la volonté de lever tout
ce qui peut sembler déblocage rapide a
levé aujourd'hui va être faite et que
l'investissement commun entre les
collectivités locales et l'état pour
aller vers un maillage qui
couvre l'ensemble du territoire et vous
l'avez entendu à très nombreuses
reprises le président de la république
l'actuel président la république à
l'époque candidat s'est exprimé sur le
sujet l'engagement son engagement et sa
volonté est très grande
voilà donc pour cette audition de cécile
duflot la ministre de l'égalité des
territoires et du logement
prochain rendez vous de l'actualité
parlementaire aujourd'hui à 16h30 pour
l'examen en séance publique du projet de
loi sur le harcèlement sexuel
vous pouvez bien sûr retrouver toutes
les séances sur notre site
publicsenat.fr
très bonne journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires